alors moi je vais t'aider un truc c'est
bien beau de dire c'est profitaient pas
on est entraîné à longueur de journée au
gouvernement n'est pas tous deux
critiqué l'attitude des français qui met
pas la marque qui se réunissait le patou
pippa poum birao lui il te dis non il
n'y a pas de désaveu vague et si tout le
monde se tiennent comme il faut mettez
nakaya pas du sport nous on avait
toutefois bien écoutez moi bien avancé
route amassés en été c'est vrai là où il
ya le toit pourquoi il ya eu les
vacances ils sont arrivés tous les mecs
tout partout ses deux filles et travail
et la regarde aujourd'hui à paris ce qui
se passe tu écoutes les informations à
paris vous allez être peut-être
continuer parce qu'il ya peña money qui
n'est pas tout nous à marcel et hérite
bière ne demandez rien dit et tout le
mois de mai qui venu pendant les
vacances il sait pas que tout le monde
allait faire n'importe quoi
alors vive la même veine si tout va bien
si tout le mois de mai des marques et
s'il n'y a pas des réunions de fu panda
2 connaît bien tout ça dans un meilleur
état que ça en moi je regarde dan martin
tiers est las d'écouter l'avis qu'il
était malade il a dit qu'il était mal
élevés impoli eux
bah oui alors oui c'est vrai voilà c'est
pourquoi il est mal poli pourquoi voilà
un nom est chez ferrari c'est d'abord
comment ça se fait qu'il ya qu elle qu
il était vu ou pas ce que ton lui il est
navré elle au moins le laisser parler
keith griffin et de parler mais elle lui
pose une autre question mais l'autre là
tout cela c'est plus jade a séjourné il
est beau et moi si j'étais vite et par
ces genres demain j'irai donc dis-moi ce
que tu veux a notamment commencé voilà
jean michel est alors énorme et saignant
mais là on n'est pas au courant non pas
comptoir de son bar
c'est délirant j'ai pris le pas car tu
défends tu me où j'aime j'aime pas c'est
le même état de pannes carte g20 et le
bail à quelle date il passe son temps à
star trek rue la barbichette et
regardent même pas les gens parce qu'ils
sont certainement pas de sa hauteur donc
ils les méprisent tellement qui la
regardent même pas dans les yeux
décrié par ses confrères regarde les
soeurs il y les bons coups remis en
question par tous ses confrères tu va
nous dire ce que tu en penses quoi
après les quatre saisons de vivaldi on a
les quatre mutations du professeur
didier raoult
alors c'est problématique puisqu'il
avait dit lors de la commission de ces
nains le 15 septembre dernier que le
virus était plus gentil elle elle serait
plus méchant le problème que posent les
études du professeur raoul c'est
qu'elles ont été construites à l'envers
quand on est scientifique et qu'on
affirme haut et fort qu'on a trouvé
l'eau traitement du cobp idée que deux
ou trois mois plus tard on s'aperçoit
que le traitement miracle n'en fait pas
de miracle on se dit que le virus aime
décidément nous montrer qu'on doit
rester modeste didier raoult a causé
énormément de confusion et qui portent
une responsabilité on peut pas dire
autrement
désolé par une responsabilité surtout ce
qu'il a dit qu'ils étaient souvent faux
je suis sûr qu'il n'y croyait pas
lui-même a beau dans beaucoup de
situations
qu'est ce que vous répondez michel mais
[Musique]
les maux d'estomac promène doliprane
c'est des médecins ne me dis pas au
temps que ce genre de mec à qui ce sont
des plateaux la tendance et chroniqueur
je ne sais pas il critique le 1er
décembre
c'est ainsi que deux zones des plus
grands scientifiques du monde s'est
trompé
l'amertume est ce le fait qu'ils
travaillent le plus fait plus le docteur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais juste non mais juste parce que
je trouve dommage avec le professeur out
c'est que honnêtement il a été un espoir
au début on aurait aimé y croire mais
honnêtement il est dit que des conneries
après tu peux juger parce que tu nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]